[Music]
let's go to liz in maui hey liz what's
up
hi dr john thanks for taking my call
thank you for calling what's happening
i just wanna let you know this call
could go south at any minute i've got a
two-year-old a three-year-old and a
four-year-old home all home quarantining
wow
[Laughter]
we could just stop the call right there
and
how about this son of a week i have a
great idea you take the phone
and just go to sleep and just put it by
your head and that way your kids may not
bother you for a second and i'll just
sit here in silence and we'll just take
10 minutes for you the whole country
will just sit with you wow that's a lot
hey no problem moment of silence yes so
what's up
uh so
uh my issue today you know i got a lot
of them but one for today
um
my mother-in-law was living with us for
an amount of time and then a
old boyfriend came back into her
into her life and she decided to go
and
live with him in her car on the beach
which is what we call homeless in hawaii
actually um this is a i learned this in
grad school that's actually homeless
everywhere in all of all of earth
oliver well i guess when it's on the
beach in hawaii it seems a little bit
more romantic
um so which was fine her choice her life
she's you know a six-year-old adult she
can do what she wants
but um the relationship has been
abusive
and she has come back
twice
like left him came back lived with us
and the second time she brought bed bugs
with her
oh
those are the worst
yeah did you get them
yes oh gosh
i i for years i was over residence halls
at universities and dude
kids would bring those this is called
ugh they're the worst and they don't
ever go away you have to just
burn your house down and rebuild
a new one
not really but yeah they're the worst
i'm sorry that's terr that's tough
yep it's just constant cleaning and
spraying and hey at least you don't have
three little kids that could get bed
bugs too
oh man what a mess what a mess
so how can i help so
that was kind of like
the last straw almost you know we took
that risk we knew that she had the bed
bugs in her car
got her car treated
did everything you know precaution wise
we could to keep the bed bugs out
um got them anyways but that was a risk
that we took and it was like you know
mom for you to have a safe place like
that's fine
you know we'll take that risk we'll deal
with it together
but then she went back
to the exact same place where she was
with the same guy
and
um now she's been reaching out like she
misses the kids
right now we're in quarantine anyways
don't really need to respond to her yet
but
um
i don't know how to respectfully and
with dignity
tell her like hey you know we can't be
your safe landing place
you know when you're putting our family
at risk every time yeah
that one's hard huh
what's your what's your husband how is
he handling this
um well he just doesn't uh he just
doesn't deal with it
[Music]
him and his mom have
this isn't new to him
her choosing
a boyfriend or herself over
over family
so that's been his
story his whole life
so a question i have
for her
have you all sat down and given her very
clear boundaries
um
and here's what here's what i'm getting
at here's what i'm getting at
i often find myself blaming somebody
for the way that they interact with me
without taking full ownership
that i am responsible for the way i
allow people to treat me and my family
and if i haven't said if this happens
this is the consequence you think we
think we don't have to do that with
adults and it would be a perfect world
if we didn't but we do it's just reality
so have you all sat down and said
if you bring home a disease if you bring
home bugs if you come here intoxicated
if you come here on drugs or high you
cannot be a part of this house
we'll love you and see you out on the
beach for hot dogs but you are not
welcome here have y'all sat down and
been that clear with her
um
no we haven't and i guess part of the
thing is
um
we've been helping out family a lot
lately and we're just we're just kind of
done with it like we just want everybody
to take care of themselves
and wouldn't that be so nice
yeah and you could just leave
and what's ironic about what you're
saying is
you just want to deal with your five and
four and three-year-old right and your
husband and which is
an
unbelievable amount of work anyway
um
back to the boundary conversation
have you had this conversation with your
husband
or are you speaking in we in the plural
because it helps prop you up because it
sounds to me like you were all
freaking alone
if it was up to my husband he just would
not talk to her not deal with her
okay at all unless she like showed up to
the house okay so he's done done with
her
yeah he's just over it okay
but i know she's also my kid's
grandmother right
and she's been messaging me that she
wants to see them that she misses us
and
um
[Music]
yeah and that's hard especially if my
husband's just like i'm done i'm just
not doing it
so here's what's got to happen you and
your husband have to have a hard
conversation i know you got three little
kids
and it's gonna have to be after they go
to bed or they're taking naps or
something somebody's gonna come over and
watch them and you all gotta have a hard
conversation
and here's the two parts to your
conversation number one it's
what is our
boundaries when it comes to mom
are we serious if she shows up in the
middle of the night
are we gonna not let her in
or yes we'll let her in when she comes
but only when she knocks on the door and
only right so what are our boundaries
however hard they are
the second part of this conversation has
to be your or what moment
if she comes banging on the door at 11
o'clock looking for a place to sleep are
y'all going to call the cops on her if
she won't leave
like what is your or what how far does
these how willing are you to hold these
boundaries
and then
the right thing i believe
because we're not talking about she's
not abusive she's not um
she's bringing chaos to you but it's
it's secondhand chaos right
i think the right thing to do is when
you and your husband come to agreement
you'll shake on this you all kiss on
this you all bump foreheads together i
don't know whatever y'all do right you
all say this is in stone
we agree on this
and i think for the first time you need
to be open and honest with him about how
you feel about how he's responding how
your your mother-in-law's response
you all need to bring mother-in-law into
this and have a conversation and hand it
to her in writing too
so that she knows we love you
and part of your boundary may be you are
welcome to live with us but you cannot
see this man anymore
you're welcome to live with us but if
you live here you're here
and if you're gonna live under
talk about
flipping the rules around if you're
gonna live under our roof it's our rules
right and if you're not
we respect your right to sleep on the
beach with some
abusive wackadoo if you'd like to we
will not participate that in that and we
will not have our kids around that
and ultimately she will say so you're
telling me i got to choose between this
and this yes
because we're making adult decisions now
with our boundaries
and hear me say liz
this will be the hardest thing you ever
do it's hard
hard heart not the hardest thing you
ever do i can tell you've been through
some stuff this will be hard
and any other family members you have
same thing same level of boundaries so
when i say that out loud how does that
sound
um i mean
we're both
veterans we're used to confrontation
it's not something that we shy away from
i think it's just finding that middle
ground
of
um you know while she's making the
choice
to
stay with this guy who is not good for
her
you know
but then am i enabling her by telling
her that she's always got a safe place
um she's always got somewhere to fall i
mean yeah y'all are y'all are the safety
net when she goes
walking on a tightrope and i don't know
that that's a bad thing
it's going to get very confusing for
your your kids
yes and
i don't i i couldn't let my mom just sit
on the front porch you know what i mean
but also i'm thinking of my mom and
she's not an addict and she
makes good decisions right so it's
different
yes
but i also have known families that have
said you can't come into the house for
addiction issues for violence issue
whatever and it was 1 000 the right
thing
what's holding you back from pulling the
trigger on this
um
what do you think's gonna happen
i guess part of it too is that it's not
my mom like if it was my mom i would be
i would go there and kick her butt and
drag her
by her hair
but uh my mom wouldn't be in that
situation yeah
so that it's not my own mother
my mother-in-law and then i'm just
trying to show her
um respect
and
just just find the right words to do
like you know hey let's meet up at the
park with the kids and you can see them
then so but you're not coming to my
house there you go
while you're dating this fool right and
you're trying to respect her and she is
not respecting her grandkids she's not
respecting her son she's not respecting
you
and i'm not saying that's licensed to
not be respectful i don't think so i
think that's the problem in the world
it's like oh you're not respecting me
then i'm not respecting and then we all
act like three-year-olds
that's not the point but you do you have
a responsibility to respect yourself
and respect your husband and respect the
boundaries of your home and your kids
and allowing this mess in your home
sounds like it's disrespectful
and i love the idea i love that you
found an alternative you found a middle
ground which is
if you want to see the kids you can see
them we'll meet you at the park we go to
the park every thursday at three o'clock
you are welcome to join us there we'd
love to see you there
and that's the boundary we're drawing
that's hard
but it sounds to me like it's right does
it sound right to you
it does good i guess just the issue is
you know with her bouncing back and
forth
yeah i i mean
again you said it when you at the
beginning of the call she's 60. you she
can do what you're going to do
it's you and your husband saying what
are we going to tolerate in our home
we're not going to accept the toggling
back and forth
or you get one shot at our house and
then when you leave we are assuming that
you are choosing him over us you're
allowed to do that good for you here's
our boundaries because we want our kids
to have that stability we want our kids
to have that openness we want our kids
to have that
um firm foundation of relationships
it's hard
and maybe there's a part of you that
looks at your husband and says get down
on the beach
and get your mom and tell her to come
home
and if you feel that way about him
if you feel like he's not stepping up to
the plate in the same way you would not
in a mean way not an ugly way nothing uh
i talk
tell him
go get your mom
go get your mom and she's 60 she can do
what she wants
but man there's something about
something about that lost sheep
i'ma go get you and bring you home